para todas las Abuelas
de Plaza de Mayo, yo soy una más.
Porque mi historia es igual
a la de mis compañeras.
Nos juntamos con un dolor enorme,
sin saber qué hacer,
con desconocimiento, peligro,
y dejando todo.
Yo era directora de una escuela,
me jubilé para buscar a ese ser querido.
Un hijo, una hija.
Pero con una doble búsqueda.
Porque esa hija estaba
esperando un bebé.
Con la edad que tengo, nací en el '30,
las dictaduras me educaron.
Pero jamás me imaginé que iba a venir
este último golpe cívico militar,
con un proyecto tan terrorífico,
tan siniestro.
O sea que tuve que educarme,
tuve que formarme, tuve que entender.
Pero hicimos algo maravilloso,
que creo que es lo que nos permitió
seguir luchando hasta ahora:
nos dimos las manos.
Dijimos, aunque estaba sola
y había otra señora como yo,
con el mismo dolor, la misma cara,
animarse y preguntar:
"¿Y a vos qué te pasa?" Y decir: "Busco".
"Mañana vamos juntas".
Y así fuimos sumando a este grupo
que ya tiene casi 37 años.
Y nos miramos todavía,
las que sobrevivimos,
porque ya muchas no están,
otras están enfermitas,
tan distintas somos, en ideología,
en cultura, en religión,
pero hay algo, ese tronco de dolor,
de lucha, que no termina jamás
porque no creo que una mamá deje de amar
un sólo día a un hijo o una hija,
y más si busca al hijo, al hijito.
Entonces fue juntarnos y empezar a buscar
sin saber cómo ni dónde.
Primero eran bebés, nadie nos decía nada.
Nunca los trajeron.
Preparamos un ajuar,
un lugarcito en la casa,
acomodamos la familia.
Después ya dejamos la familia,
cambiamos el rol que teníamos,
de mamás, de esposas,
y de docente en mi caso,
y ese lugar lo ocupó mi esposo,
porque a veces nos preguntan:
"¿Dónde están los abuelos?"
Los abuelos estuvieron.
Yo los califico como los héroes anónimos,
porque ellos tuvieron que tomar el rol
de seguir con los hijos que quedaban,
de traer el alimento, y de esperarnos,
porque salíamos y ellos no sabían
si íbamos a volver.
Yo recuerdo que una vez, un poco
desanimada, y no sé por qué dije:
"Me parece que no voy más".
Y él me dijo, mi marido:
"No, tenés que seguir,
porque las Abuelas te necesitan".
Fue la única vez, y nunca más
sentí ganas de dejar nada. Al contrario.
Uds. saben que encontré a mi nieto, que
nos encontramos, que estamos conviviendo.
¡Momentos!
(Aplausos)
Pero yo quiero compartir con Uds.,
porque a mi nieto no lo encontré yo sola.
Las Abuelas, pero todos Uds. también,
porque nos fueron dando,
con el correr del más largo período
de democracia argentina,
nos fueron dando las manos, porque
fueron entendiendo que la dictadura
nos tocó a todos,
que no tiene que volver a pasar,
que hay que rescatar
estos desaparecidos con vida.
O sea que mi nieto es el nieto de todos,
por eso fíjense que pasó algo maravilloso:
hay como una especie de sonrisa general
en nuestro país desde este encuentro.
No sé si es por la lucha de esta mujer,
de 37 años, desde el amor, sin odios,
sin rencores, simplemente queriendo
que esto no vuelva a pasar,
que se tengan hijos para que vivan
en libertad, que puedan pensar,
disentir, pero ser hermanos.
Por eso me parece que este encuentro
multitudinario, maravilloso, de Uds.,
en este espacio cultural, debe cimentar
la convivencia a pesar de las diferencias.
Fíjense, las Abuelas, hoy en día hasta
discutimos cosas que no compartimos
pero cuando hay que decidir algo, firmes.
Y hemos dejado, por suerte, y a veces digo
"Qué cosa rara que diga gracias a la vida,
a pesar del dolor".
Porque mi hija dio la vida
sabiendo que había que cambiar,
y están cambiando las cosas.
Y dejamos caminos abiertos inexplorados.
Uno es la ciencia. No hay en el mundo
un banco nacional de datos genéticos
donde abuelas estén buscando esos nietos
que una dictadura les robó.
Somos el único país que tiene una historia
de búsqueda de esos bebés que son adultos.
¡Pero qué alegría cuando
el encuentro se produce!
¡La felicidad! Yo me siento más joven,
me siento mejor.
A veces tengo ganas de tirar este bastón,
pero también digo que lo tengo porque
las Abuelas nunca nos arrodillamos,
siempre caminamos, de pie, con fuerza,
con empeño, con respeto.
Porque no es necesario agredir
para conseguir la justicia.
La justicia está llegando.
Y yo creo que dejamos un granito de arena
en esta democracia que esperemos que sea
la democracia para siempre.
(Aplausos)
Yo les deseo en estos breves minutos
de charla lo mejor para todos.
Creo que si están acá es porque son
los argentinos que merecen respeto,
que merecen ser escuchados y
darle satisfacción a sus demandas.
Lo más importante es no estar solos.
Lo más importante es no cansarse.
Porque la perseverancia triunfa.
Míren, yo, 37 años, hoy acá, les digo:
Gracias por ayudarme
a encontrar a mi nieto.
Porque vale la pena luchar.
Muchísimas gracias.
(Aplausos)